So we've now made some changes
to our envision prototype.
We've add in the check boxes and
we've changed our home screen.
Now in order to do user research
with it we've put it on a phone and
we'll bring in users to test with it.
Johnathan, how do we go about
putting it onto this phone?
>> It's simple Jay, all you need to do
is click on the Sharelink button, and
click SMS.
When you click the share link button,
you'll have an option to choose how
you want to share your project.
Simply click the SMS button, and turn
the phone number that you'd like to send
a text to, and it'll automatically
send the text directly to your phone.
When you open up the text,
it'll have a link
that'll allow you to download
the prototype directly onto your phone.
>> And now we're going to bring in
Jeremy to start testing our app.